you went to Alan's party I went to
Alan's party was it a good party I can't
talk about it what what tell me a story
about Ellen's party I was supposed to be
there actually I did get invited no I I
was you know done and and I went to go
see my ride and my ride wasn't ready to
leave yet so I smoked a joint with some
rappers and OH
their [ __ ] is different right I entered
a different universe oh dear and then I
went to the porta potti to copy and
there was a woman there and she was like
no no no go on go ahead and I was like
no no you were here first you go and she
was like mhm go and I was like ok and so
I'm in the port-a-potty I'm like she's
got a poop you know it's probably right
I'm smart and and so I came out and I
made a beeline for her and I went up to
her and I was like look you got a poop
and she was like no I don't know why
you're saying that like I really don't I
was like you left to poop she was kind
of laughing but was like no and all of a
sudden security is grabbing me because
what I hadn't realized is I am grabbing
this woman by the shoulders shaking her
screaming oh you have to poop you have
to cope and the security guard is
laughing so hard cuz he's heard the
whole exchange he's like you can't grab
her but I agree she's got a pull and so
she and I were just on the ground
laughing and the woman finally started
laughing and I was just like just poop
oh my god it was just a famous woman I
don't I gotta find out who she is you
were so high you acted inappropriately
yes wow what is that [ __ ] then I got
McDonald's on the way back